after that trial we will know
will rapamycin be useful in
in older people
so hello and welcome to the chicky
science show where in this video i had
the great pleasure of speaking with dr
brad stanfield a medical doctor trained
in new zealand
who is also a youtuber sharing the
latest research around why we age and if
we are closer to finding ways to extend
our health span in this discussion we
talk about brad's recently announced
raphael in human trial as well as his
other interests in the field
so hi brad thank you for joining me
today and welcome to the chicky science
show it's great to have you on
yeah thanks very much for having me
so um as you recently announced on your
youtube channel you've recently launched
this rapamycin human trial so i was just
wondering if you could first just
discuss where did this idea come from
like why did this whole thing originate
from
yeah so one of the big things that we're
trying to do is slow down muscle decline
as we age so
there's a quite alarming stat that once
we reach the age of 40 our muscle mass
declines from by about one percent per
year and the decline in muscle actually
starts in your 30s so
if we can slow down muscle decline in
older adults that is huge because it
means that we you know we still have the
strength to do the things that we want
to do we don't have to spend as much
time in rest homes and we can actually
give back to the world for a longer
period in our lives so i find that quite
inspiring
and we've already got a fantastic way of
slowing down the muscle decline process
and that's exercise so if we exercise
particularly with resistance training we
can slow down that muscle decline so
but but that's still not enough our
muscles strength overall still goes down
so it's important to try and find
methods that can go alongside exercise
to help us hold on to as much muscle
strength as we can
so one of the
um one of the things that the body does
when we exercise it activates an enzyme
called mtor so mtor
when you activate it it tries to build
up proteins and build up your muscle
strength um
and it's almost like the body realizes
that
it's
weaker as we age and it seems to over
activate mtor in our muscles the trouble
is when you're over activating mtor
you're not actually building any any
more proteins and you're stopping a
process called autophagy so autophagy is
just where the body clears away its old
cell components so it seems that as we
age our muscles or our muscle cells are
just holding on they're holding on to
these old damaged mitochondria and old
cell components not flushing any of it
away
and so it seems like we need periods of
time where we're activating mtor and
building new muscle building proteins
but also periods of time where we're
switching mtor off so that we can
activate autophagy and it's almost like
a cleaning house process
um so that's where rapamycin comes in so
rapamycin it switches off mtor so
hopefully if we have periods of time
where we're using mtor uh sorry where
we're using rapid mice and switching off
mtor we're clearing away those old
components ready so that new components
can be made so that's the overall gist
of the study
oh so did this come from you did some
research about um the the link between
muscle and empty activity and then
from your reading as well about
rapamycin that's where the idea came
from or was it like you just really
wanted to do a trial um specifically for
muscle like well yeah where did the
initial drive to do a trial come from
and like is this your first trial that
you're doing
yeah so
i've been involved in other research
projects um sort of as a medical student
and as a medical doctor none of it's
really had to do with longevity though
or so-called health span um it's been in
things like appendicitis and whatnot um
so this this would be my first clinical
trial looking at ways to slow down or
improve health span in humans um
this idea can't yeah
one of the things i'm a little bit
concerned about in the so-called health
span or longevity space
um is the emphasis that's put on
biomarkers that that are measured from
you know blood or or tissue samples
because
so let's take dna methylation clocks for
example so they're a way to see how how
old is your dna and people are starting
to design trials around that to say if
you take a particular molecule or you do
a particular exercise you can hopefully
reverse your dna age
i'm a bit concerned about the emphasis
that's placed on that because i think
what's really important is functional
outcomes so what i mean by that is will
you have lower rates of heart disease
will you be able to exercise for longer
periods of time
will you get sick less often
i think those are the
markers or
functional outcomes that we should be
measuring and
making sure that we're emphasizing those
in the clinical trials that are run so
um when it comes to rapamycin when it's
tested in mice in particular with the
interventions testing program on average
it extends lifespan by about 20
and i think that's that's pretty awesome
in itself but not necessarily why i'm
excited about rapamycin it there seems
to be a signal particularly in male mice
that if so the male mice who take
rapamycin they seem to be more active
in their older years compared to those
mice who don't take rapamycin so
i think that's the holy grail of what
we're trying to do with healthspan is
being able to allow people to do the
activities that they want to do in their
old age and have the strength to do that
and so when us when i started looking
into rapamycin to see how it works
um
and the the potential benefits in humans
i wanted to see what is a trial that we
can design to actually figure out if
rapamycin would be useful for humans and
it seems that
with this potential mechanism of
rapamycin particularly if it's used
intermittently it may improve exercise
performance as we age and you can trial
that and actually come up with a quite
yeah you can design a robust trial
around it and get some good clinical
data
cool yeah so as you mentioned with the
rapamycin studies center mice um like at
the itp i think one of the the good
things about it and why a lot of people
are excited about rapamycin was i guess
firstly the fact that it works in both
males and females in terms of improving
their lifespan and then the second thing
was that it also worked even if the mice
were giving it very late in their life
so it wasn't like they had to have it
from like age or not age 20 but the
equivalent and in mice um but but
obviously there's also been some
concerns about rapamycin obviously the
first one being that currently it's
already used as like an
immunosuppressant and it's also a study
suggesting that
rapamycin may cause glucose intolerance
um and maybe
maybe also be linked to diabetes and so
given the kind of concerns associated
with rapamycin and also the good
benefits how are you incorporating that
information into the into the other side
of the trial that you want to conduct
yeah so as you mentioned rapamycin it's
already used in clinical medicine so if
people have um a kidney transplant
rapamycin is also used to help
the body not reject that organ um so
what actually seems to be happening with
rapamycin is that it helps the other
medications that stop that organ
rejection from working
to actually work properly um rapamycin
in of itself wouldn't really stop um
that organ from being rejected so
yes it is used as an immunosuppressant
in in clinical medicine but it's more to
help the other immunosuppressant
medications work more effectively
and when it comes to having a look at
um rapamycin's potential effects on
lowering the immune system there's
actually there's been a couple of trials
looking to see whether rapamycin would
actually improve um
the immune system in humans so
there's this concept called
immunosenescence which is essentially
where um
yeah as you as we age our immune system
isn't as effective as what it once used
to be um
and it's using the same process that if
we can clear away these old components
maybe then we can have a more effective
immune system so
the human trial and that's important
this was a human trial that was done it
looked at rapamycin and
and combining it with the
influenza vaccine and i wanted to see
what the what the effects were
and in the initial trial um it looked
like with the um with the influenza
vaccine there was actually a more
effective response to the influenza
vaccine when rapamycin was taken in in
larger subsequent trials that actually
it seems to be about even so so that
that's kind of stopped that um that
research kind of dead in its tracks but
i think what's the important takeaway
from that is that rapamycin certainly
doesn't look to reduce the effect of the
influenza vaccine and possibly it may
even improve it so
with the
with the concerns around the
immunosuppressive effects
i i do wonder whether it's slightly
overblown particularly with the dosages
that we
are proposing in this trial so
typically the um to to help stop organ
rejection rapamycin is used every day
and it's used in dosages between
you know so so you generally start at
six milligrams and and you work up from
there to to build up the the correct
dose with the trial that i'm proposing
would be using five milligrams once a
week so it's a massively lower dose
compared to what is actually currently
used in medicine and again that's
because we do want periods of time where
we're switching mtor off and that's
where we use rapamycin but we also want
periods of time where we're exercising
and we're switching mtor on so
that that's the overall um
yeah that's my overall thoughts around
the immunosuppressive effects but you've
touched on
something interesting with the diabetic
effects um
we're not exactly sure why
so
in in the human data that that's come
out looking at rapamycin and seeing
whether that that increases blood sugar
levels and increases the diabetic rates
it's quite difficult to tease out
whether it's rapamycin that's doing that
or whether it's the other
um whether it's the other medications
that that those patients were on
so it's it's tricky to know um but but
again with those trials the rapamycin
has been used every day as opposed to
once a week so in this trial we'll
definitely be measuring
you know blood sugar levels and the
hba1c to make sure that we're not
causing new diabetes um
but i'm not i'm not at this point
concerned that we would be causing new
diabetes but again that data will bear
out in the trial we want to make sure
that this trial is as robust as possible
and bulletproof as possible because
if if we do it a good trial how awesome
would it be that we've got a way to
actually slow down muscle decline in
older people and
it's only going to be high quality data
that will actually get this treatment
into the correct hands if it works
yeah that's a really good answer and so
the trial you're doing you're planning
to do at the moment that involves party
participants you're hoping for um so
it's just um more like a preliminary
trial before you try to expand to larger
numbers beside the idea
yeah essentially we don't have any human
data at the moment that combines
exercise with rapamycin so this initial
data is primarily to make sure that the
the trial design is bulletproof so that
we can do a much larger trial in the
future um it's it's to make sure that
we're not causing any adverse side
effects to exercise
but also most importantly our primary
outcome for this paper and i think it's
quite important to
um before we do any trial it's to
actually outline what the primary
endpoint would be to make this trial a
success or not because otherwise you
know we can get all this data we can
look we can look back at it and see what
may have actually improved um during the
trial and that's called sort of p-value
hacking um and that's essentially poor
science so the the primary outcome here
that we want to figure out is will
once a week rapamycin improve
the 30 second chair stand test so that's
where you know how many times can you
stand up and sit back down in a chair
over a 30 second time frame so
what we want to do is take people um so
in their older years so at least sort of
60 years old and who don't already
exercise that frequently
and we want to see if we exercise them
what happens to their 30-second chair
stand test because
we want to be able to see is there a
change in that test um
if if we take people who are really
quite fit
and and we we continue exercising them
we're probably not going to see their 30
second chest and test change that much
during the trial and then it's quite
tricky to to see well is rapamycin
improving things is it worsening things
or is it having no effect because that
you know that the numbers are going to
be roughly the same so what we want to
try and figure out is if we take people
who are at least 60 years old and we
exercise them will that and well how
much will that improve their 30-second
chair stand test and then we can do a
power calculation so we can actually
figure out how many people do we need in
a much larger so-called superiority
trial
to see will rapamycin actually
improve the 30 seconds chair stand test
or on or not um so so that's the overall
trial it's trying to make sure that yes
it's safe um that the design is
bulletproof and that we can actually do
a power calculation for the larger
superiority trial i see and so um if i
understand correctly then so you're what
kind of makes your trial different from
i guess the more recently announced
powell trial which is also looking at
rapamycin and i guess broadly human
longevity um
is the fact that you're combining it
with exercise and so you have periods
where they take graphomycin once a week
and then when they're not taking
rapamycin it's when you have the
exercise so you get this kind of like
alternating
activation passes inhibition
yeah so that's one of the big
differences the one of the other
differences is we're looking at a
functional outcome so i'm i'm very
excited to read the pearl trial i think
they've done a fantastic job getting
that trial underway
their primary end point and it's
fantastic that they actually said what
their primary endpoint is going to be
it's a dexa scan and they're looking at
you know what is the essentially ratio
between fat mass and muscle mass and
will taking rapamycin improve that ratio
so i think that's important data um
but
again i i do want to focus in on a
functional outcome as in what what is
the exercise performance difference is
going to be if you take rapid mice and
versus if you don't so it's kind of two
big differences between the pearl trial
and i think i think
both trials that they they go alongside
each other quite well i don't think that
one child is better than the other i
just think that that they're answering
different questions and i i think
overall it'll help us build a picture as
to whether taking rapamycin in humans is
a good idea or not
yeah can it make sense and so i think
the other thing that's interesting about
your design is how it kind of somewhat
resonates the current literature
surrounding um diets and fasting so for
example protein is one thing that's
known to activate m productivity
um and it's also
been linked suggested to have low
protein diets
up until the age of about 65 when you
should start having more protein as
you've mentioned due to muscle atrophy
and so i guess that kind of links into
the design whereby we don't continuously
want to be inhibiting mtor but we need
to have those those um periods where
it's also getting activated to ensure
that we get
um muscle building as well and so you've
mentioned a little bit about the
exercise but could you elaborate a bit
more exactly what type of exercise are
they going to be doing and like how long
yeah so
again we're taking older people who
don't already exercise so we need to
come up with a exercise program that is
going to be palatable
to them um because these aren't going to
be people who are yeah fit and already
doing um the exercise program so
particularly with covert times i think
it's important that we that we have an
exercise program that people can do at
home
so um there's a
there's an online
um
platform for exercise that's
specifically designed for older people
so what we want to do is get them to do
those exercises at home um and that they
can do extra exercise if they want to
but we definitely want them to be able
to do
these at home um exercise programs and
it's just it's sort of like a whole body
um
uh
exercise program um so that's yeah it's
not going to be trying to get them to go
to the gym and doing hardcore um you
know high-intensity interval training so
i think i think that would probably be
the the best type of exercise to do but
again we're taking people that don't
already exercise so we need we need to
try and find a program that will work
for them and work within their busy
lives
i see
and so what was it that led you to
choose rapamycin over i guess other um
like supplements that have been also
shown to have different benefits for
like health span um i guess mainly in
different model organisms such as for
example alpha ketoglutarate which is i
guess an interesting example because
obviously it's already like i guess
bodybuilders uh take a form of um
arginine akg which is therefore used for
like um muscle growth as well so but
then there was also a study that came
out last year that showed akg and the
calcium salt fashion given to my
extensor lifespan and so i guess that
would have been an interesting um
choice as well so did you consider other
possibilities
yeah absolutely and i think
you've touched on a point there's so
many exciting avenues um to go down and
it's quite tricky to if you are going to
choose one particular molecule it is
quite tricky to to choose that one
molecule
why i chose rapamycin is because of the
data that's come out from the
interventions testing program
so
over and over again when they test it
and they're very rigorous with their
experiments you do get that lifespan
extension and particularly with
with the um theory around mtor and
switching it on and off as we age
i think that is quite powerful
so i i'm overall more excited about the
potential that rapamycin has
but if i had all of the resources in the
world i would definitely want to be
trialing akg as well
yeah good answer um and so with this
child that you're currently setting up
like what's the kind of time scale that
you're working with at the moment like
how long do you think it will take you
to get it started and then like how long
will it take you to gather the data and
like when yeah when are we going to see
the results
yeah a lot of it depends on the the
fundraising campaign so we've just
started a fundraising campaign we
partnered with um lifespan.io and we're
running a fundraiser through youtube and
i'm also trying to see if there's these
other larger investors or people who are
interested in this field to see if they
want to donate to this trial because
yeah that's the limiting factor to to do
these trials well
it's very expensive to do but i think
it's important that we that we do
put that cost um that that we do invest
uh in these in trials like this because
it's this high quality data that's going
to shift the needle so
yeah um if if this trial was fully
funded would probably want to start it
early next year
and then this is an initial proof of
concept trial
so would we certainly want to finish it
so so it's a three month trial and would
probably want to finish that within
about six months because it's going to
take time with the recruitment uh
process and people would be doing the
trial at different time points um
so you know end of end of next year
would be pretty awesome to have the data
and and then we would use that data to
springboard to the much larger
superiority trial but for that trial
i'm i'm guessing would probably need
around
400 people in total so it's a it's a
much larger trial that would actually
tell us will rapamycin actually work in
humans to help that muscle building
process
or not um so it is good it is going to
be years unfortunately until we've got a
definitive answer but i think with this
pathway we will get a definitive answer
yeah i agree um and so if you had like i
guess additional funding for this trial
like how would you actually try and
improve the design you already have in
place would it be a matter of maybe
taking additional uh biomarkers that you
would look at i mean yeah what what are
your thoughts about this
if i had additional yeah i've kind of
designed the trial um
exactly how i'd want to i i've left no
no stone unturned particularly for the
larger superiority trial so what with
that trial would be measuring other
things um such as you know the
microbiome markers to see what rapamycin
would do um to that but again i think
it's
um i i do think it's quite important to
focus in on those functional outcomes
which we're measuring already everything
else i think is is nice to to measure
but it's the functional outcomes that i
think we need to focus on and that's
what we're measuring
so yeah what
my overall dream would be if if if
rapamycin does
prove to work and i think that that's
the that's the thing what we don't know
if it's going to improve muscle function
or not but at least with this trial
we'll be able to find out if it does
if it does it will be quite cool to to
trial other molecules and you know
you've mentioned akg if that works in in
older
people as well and then if you do a
trial that combines both of those
treatments will you get even more added
benefits so so that's kind of
my trajectory and in terms of the trials
that i'd love to run but yeah
we can't we can't sprint before we can
walk that's true
yes good answer um so it seems like
everything's very exciting um for the
trolls so yeah i'm really excited um
to see how this progresses and i believe
i'll be putting the fundraising link in
my description somehow so people can fun
um donate if they want to
um but moving as besides the the rapper
myself um
i mean how are you managing to juggle
this along with youtube at the moment
yeah it's pretty tricky so yeah my
full-time job is working at the clinic
so seeing patients during the day so you
know it's 5 30 in the morning at the
moment so yeah my day typically starts
at 4 a.m to do the research that i need
to do
um for the videos that i produce and
then you know over the weekend i'm
either you know working on the rapamycin
trial or filming videos and editing them
um this is in combination with you know
i've um
i've got a
son who's almost you know one year so
trying to to raise him and then trying
to stay sane and look after my own
health so
yeah um
next year is going to be a bit easier
because i'll be stepping down to three
days a week at the clinic and i hope to
start looking after myself a little bit
better as well because i haven't been
able to you know do the exercise that i
want to do it's just simply too busy at
the moment so i'm kind of burning the
candles at both ends but i think you
know we've certainly made some quite
significant progress this year as well
and and getting this this trial underway
um yeah that's i this is a high priority
to me as well but you know overall my
patients come first so
yeah i can't let my you know youtube and
whatnot and impact my work at the clinic
so yeah it's busy but yeah certainly
gets me out of bed every day that's good
to her um and i guess speaking of the
channel itself i saw recently that one
of your like videos that you can like
blew up and tell myself views which is
all about turmeric so um could you tell
me about turmeric um yeah why is why is
a lot of interest surrounding it oh
that's a good question but i had no idea
when i produced that video that people
would be so interested interested in
turmeric so
it's turmeric's been used for thousands
of years particularly in um traditional
indian medicine
and the active ingredient within
turmeric is curcumin so it's a so-called
anti-inflammatory and
one of the
one of the reasons that it's it's um
that people are excited about it is the
trials that are coming out looking at
osteoarthritis so
most of us will be affected by arthritis
as we age and it's incredibly painful
and there's not a lot of safe treatments
that we can use in older people because
if we use things like so traditional
anti-inflammatories such as diclofenac
ibuprofen naproxen
they they are quite dangerous and older
people so i'm always extremely hesitant
to prescribe them because you know
older people generally their their
kidneys aren't in great shape their
stomachs are a bit more fragile so if
you're using those traditional
anti-inflammatories you can cause
significant damage whereas with curcumin
it looks like we can actually get the
same benefits of those traditional
anti-inflammatory medications but
without the side effects they don't seem
to cause problems with stomach bleeds or
issues with kidneys so if we can use
that and in particular if we combine
curcumin with pepperon which is a black
pepper extract to help the absorption
i i do wonder whether that's going to
become a standard treatment in in the
medical field
for arthritis so that's the research
that i'm particularly interested in and
and this kind of bore through this year
when a massive meta-analysis where they
pulled together all of the randomized
controlled trials looking at curcumin
and it looks like yeah that the benefits
are exactly the same compared to the
other anti-inflammatories so yeah i'm
excited about that in in terms of
will this help human longevity or human
health span
um
the interventions testing program trials
curcumin and there was no increased
lifespan so i don't think it's going to
increase human lifespan
um
but yeah that's that's overall just
about about that sorry i had no idea
that it was going to be that popular i
think we're just under 300 000 views now
yeah happy days
yeah well that's interesting i hadn't i
haven't really studied um the
molecular effects of curcumin too much
because um i didn't realize the link
between osteoarthritis but now that you
mentioned it it's kind of interesting
because
um
obviously osteoarthritis is somewhat
associated with the presence of
senescent cells so cells that got
damaged or become dysfunctional and
basically stopped um dividing and like
secreting inflammatory factors which
might account for some of the phenotypes
seen in patients with osteoarthritis um
but in terms of the data i have seen
surrounding a curcumin is the fact that
there was i mean it was unfeatured you
see petri dish but they basically showed
that
um
um similar to things like physin uh
curcumin also showed like synolytic
potential and so maybe that could be the
connection
to the benefits seen in these
osteoarthritis trials so that's like
quite interesting um but yeah as you say
the itv study showed that it didn't
affect the lifespan um which i guess
comes back to the whole field of
stenolytics and whether or not it's
going to be useful maybe for specific
diseases but whether or not it actually
has benefits for lifespan it might just
be healthspan obviously healthspan's
still important so
i guess in a long way this is a question
asking about your current thoughts still
on sunnyletics
yeah it's it's really tricky um
so the interventions testing program
they are going to be trialling
feisterton and using it intermittently
so i think that was part of their 2018
cohort of molecules that they were going
to trial
so it'll be interesting to see what what
that data shows
the mayo clinic is is running human
trials looking at ficerton as well so
again it'll be interesting to read that
data but it's
it's so tricky um i recently read a
paper that was
comparing um you know cancer treatment
to synalytic treatment and how actually
cancer treatment might be an easier
problem to tackle because with cancer
treatment there's specific mutations
that we can um that we can you know
target whereas with synalytic cells it's
they're still our own cells and it can
be quite tricky to design a molecule
that can
you know clear away those senescent
cells and clearing away the the right
types of senescent cells so
i i'm interested in in the field um
i i certainly hope that it's got um yeah
that it bears fruit and and i personally
take physician um so five days in a row
once a month
but who knows
we don't yet know if it's going to if
it's going to improve improve um human
health down or not but i'm curious
you're you're probably more an expert
than what i am with synalytic cells so
i'm curious to hear your latest thoughts
um yeah so i think i actually know which
paper you're talking about because i'm
pretty sure i read that too um so
basically a lot of those analytics say
things like the satanic they're kind of
just like repurposed chemotherapeutic
drugs so they're used to in cancer
treatments um and so
basically they try to target some asset
cells because they're already a bit kind
of messed up and so if you make them a
little bit worse they're more likely to
die than your healthy cells which should
be able to kind of fix the damage
but actually i guess one of the concerns
with those kind of approaches is the
fact that the kind of normal cells
instead of dying like this analytics the
so the senescent cells die which is the
analytic aspect but then it's the normal
like healthy cells get damaged and then
they become snatchmen so it's like you
get rid of someone you've made them all
kind of thing and so that's called
therapy and senescence
um obviously that's using uh
chemotherapeutic drugs but then there's
things like um facilitain and other like
proposed um i guess maybe even curcumin
if that does prove to be have synthetic
potential um more like natural compounds
that have a similar effect but um as
you've already mentioned we don't
currently know like how specific they
are or like what is it these different
compounds are binding to and how is it
they're altering the senescent states
and causing that cell
um to go from that kind of survival mode
and secreting inflammatory factors to
them going um inducing cell death um so
i mean something i find very interesting
and so um in terms of the molecular
aspect i still think it's quite unclear
and then in terms of the data as you say
there's trials in the works and i'm the
same as you just waiting to see like
when that data is going to come out so i
think that's when we're going to get a
better understanding of how it is
that acting and whether it's going to be
beneficial
um i don't know if you saw recently um
there's obviously mouse models that have
been shown
that if you clear so these mouse models
work by um showing senescent cells that
have high p16 expression which is like a
marker of cellular senescence and they
say if you clear those cells you might
be able to improve the health of these
mice um but there's not they're not the
only like types of senescent cells
there's also more is another paper came
out uh earlier this year that identified
um p21 as a marker for a different
subset of senescent cells um and if you
cleared those that also seem to show
some benefits but like
yeah there's definitely way more um we
still need to understand so that's
currently my position um i think there's
potential um i think we need to a
understands better what these compounds
are doing and secondly to get more human
data to see actually is there any
impacts and there's already maybe
um consequences or side effects
yeah absolutely and i think
when when looking at these uh molecules
actually see if they work so yes i
completely agree that it's what we need
to understand at a molecular level how
these molecules are actually working but
then with the with the human trials that
are eventually done
i do think that
coming back to the end points that we
need to have firm end points as to to
know whether these molecules will
actually work because if we're trying to
see whether these molecules will extend
human lifespan
you know we're going to be waiting
decades
but but if if we could
see you know in heart failure patients
for example if synalytic agents improve
heart function i mean that's powerful or
you know similar thing with with muscle
function um and and those are things
that that we can measure so and and i
think those types of trials will start
to get this data
or this field a lot more mainstream
because you know literally for hundreds
if not thousands of years people have
been claiming that this molecule or that
molecule or this treatment will improve
you know your health or your lifespan um
so you know we just need robust data to
come through and that's why i'm pleased
to see that the mayo clinic is actually
testing molecules such as physician to
see whether we will see these health
benefits
exactly and like i guess coming back now
to your trial again
speaking more about the endpoints like
so you say you get successful data and
it's proved that yeah rapamycin's going
to be effective what would then be the
next step on from that like how does it
go from back to then treating patients
in the clinic and going you're going to
take graphomycin like how does that all
kind of work
yeah so then it's
for me it's starting to target the the
guidelines so there's a lot of um
there's a good process in place for new
treatments that come on board to change
medical practice
and a lot of that is to do with
presenting papers or findings at
conferences and then also you know
talking to the the different um
guideline bodies so for example that
almost a creme de la creme of medical
guidelines is a database called up to
date
and it i think it costs about 500 us
dollars a year um to subscribe but it's
fantastic for clinicians and so it would
be you know presenting this trial to
them and say hey this is what we've
found
essentially do you want to update your
your guidelines as to how people should
be treated in their older years um it's
also trying to collaborate with um
um with organizations such as cochrane
so cochrane is a i think it's based in
the uk and it's a not-for-profit
organization that just looks at the raw
data to see what that data shows and and
where um
yeah whether a particular treatment will
be effective for a health condition so
it's it's engaging with um corporations
such as well not corporations but
organizations such as that to change
medical practice and again if you've got
that robust data it will change medical
practice and the treatments will get
into the hands of a lot more people
you just need that robust data first and
so far in this field i think that
there's a lot of noise and and i'm i'm
definitely part of creating that noise
um but we don't have robust data yet
that will change clinical practice but
that's one of the reasons why i'm
excited about the turmeric studies that
may actually change clinical practice
because now i think we do have that
robust data
that would suggest that we should be
recommending
curcumin to you know people that have
got osteoarthritis for their pain
yeah that's like a good uh good point
i'm so like with rapamycin again like is
that quite cheap um as a drug anyway or
like so in terms of taking it more to
widespread adoption is it
like yeah how expensive is it to
treat with rapamycin
yeah so rapamycin
just a molecule by itself it's not
particularly bioavailable so you've got
companies such as pfizer who have
created um oral versions of it so that
the one that we would be using in our
trial is called serolimus and i'm not
i'm to be honest i'm not sure the cost
of that i've applied to pfizer to see
whether they will
give us the cyrolimus and a matching
placebo for the trial um i haven't quite
heard back yet um but in terms of the
costs
i i believe sirolimus is still under
patent so i'm not sure that the exact
cost of that um
but i mean patterns do run out and i
think by the time that we've actually
got this data to show that it improves
um you know muscle performance i would
have hoped that throughout this would be
out of pattern particularly if if the
um
you know if since we're crowdfunding
this trial
no one owns that ip um
and and i i certainly don't want to
restrict anyone from from getting this
treatment if it proves to be successful
so
yeah i'm
hopefully it's not going to be too
expensive for people to to start using
it but again if it works and i think
that's the important thing that there's
many people who are taking rapamycin at
the moment um and and i just want to be
clear i certainly wouldn't
recommend taking rapamycin yet we don't
have the human clinical data to show
benefits um and and there is a little
bit still of a question mark around
safety both of which i think the pearl
trial and i'm hoping that my trial will
help to
um will help to clear up
yes granted and so we've spoken a lot
now about i guess like current um
approaches that are available but have
you read anything uh recently that's
spoken more about i mean maybe more far
future um potential therapeutics that
you think are quite interesting um
and yeah you think have potential for
for having i guess
um even more dramatic improvements in
health as opposed to just different
supplements
yeah it's it's tricky that to be honest
the the more that i read the more
the the more you realize how complex
human biology is and if you tweak
something
that can have a lot of unintended
consequences
so
the the more i read the more i
try to emphasize to my audience that as
of right now the things that we know
will improve your health span is diet
exercise sleep meditation
making sure that you're socializing with
friends and making sure that you've got
a purpose in life and i think those are
the those are the core things um i've
i've not come across any
treatment that i'm particularly excited
about that will massively extend human
lifespan or have a um
have a wildly um
yeah a wild improvement in in health
span aside from things like rapamycin
which is why i wanted to trial it um so
yeah i'm
if anything i'm a lot more reserved
compared to when i first entered this
field when i started my youtube channel
i thought that we were on the cusp of
all of these treatments coming on board
and and having quite profound effects on
human health span and lifespan
and the the more that i read the more i
realized how we are still quite a quite
a far way away from having a treatment
that everyone can get that will
have massive improvements to their
health
you know i'm kind of an agreement yeah
trying to be a bit down on the on the
yeah subject but yeah that's where i'm
kind of at that's a good answer i think
yeah i'm kind of the same i think it's
good to be kind of like skeptical a
little bit cautious like it's easy to
get swept away with like um
like certain statements and
unless you look at the data i think or
like understand the data it's it's easy
to just trust someone's opinion because
i think we're kind of somewhat inclined
to
to like
be influenced by different people so
yeah i think it's always good to take a
step back and actually look at the
bigger picture of where we actually
currently are
um so you mentioned um your channel
again i was just wondering do you have
any like future plans like you've got
the trial going you're still making
videos but do you have any um
things you want to do differently or
like improve upon with your channel
yeah yeah definitely there's always room
for improvement and one of the things
that i'm i'm still trying to work on is
my delivery of the information so i'm
definitely not a natural in front of the
camera so when i'm when i'm recording my
videos so say for a 10 minute video
it'll take me 30 or 40 minutes to
actually record um
and what one of the things that i'm
trying to work on is is trying to build
more of a story because people remember
stories that's how you know back in the
day that's how information was passed
down through the different generations
was through stories so
i'm trying to figure out a way of
presenting the data and and holding true
to that because that's how i built my
initial audience but then also trying to
pair it with some sort of a story format
and i'm not quite there yet so that's
definitely something that i want to work
on but sort of moving forward and my
overall goals
yes
presenting information is interesting
and i think it's useful so that people
are steered away from
supplements or treatments that
it's just all hype and and moving them
onto things like diet and exercise i
think that's an important role but for
me i want to leverage my um
my channel to get more trials funded and
to hopefully encourage the
the correct sorts of trials from being
conducted um so again i'd yeah it's the
functional outcomes that i'm really
trying to push on my channel at the
moment um making sure that we're not
getting led astray by different
biomarkers i mean for example the
classic one right now is the the new um
treatment that's come about for
alzheimer's disease and um
so so that's been approved by the fda
but
so so yes it looks to improve brain
health on mri scans but when you have a
look at the actual cognitive performance
of these patients on the treatment it
doesn't seem to be a benefit so
again it's it's functional outcomes that
that's what matters it's not necessarily
the biomarkers or what your blood is
telling you it's
yeah are you more resilient to disease
can you do
you know more exercise um that that's
what's that's what matters so yeah those
are the overall goals of of my channel
but yeah still
still a long way to go there's always
room for improvement yeah i can
definitely relate to that um i'm also
getting used to the whole interview
style i still don't think i'm the best
but um it just again comes a practice
right
um
but um that all sounds really exciting
and as you say i think it's great that
we can use like youtube as a platform to
fundraise for these things and as i said
earlier like i would attempt to put it
into my description so you should be
able to to help fundraise for this trial
as well um if you want to um and so
probably of interest to my audience um
you've mentioned a bit about how you
take um physician but what else um do
you do at the moment based on the
current literature that you think is
hopefully um helping your health
yeah so i think that's important it's
i'm taking these molecules hoping that
it will improve my health more than than
placebo and so my um in each of my
videos that i've got a link to my
current supplement stack
um so you know i i do take a bunch of
things um
so i i take things like niacin or
nicotinic acid and that's to try and
help
make my overall nad metabolism more
resilient to
you know when i'm staying up at night
burning the midnight oil trying to do
youtube scripts um
i you know i take things like magnesium
at night
and
there is potentially some evidence
around brain health and also sleep
um
i take creatine i think creatine is to
be honest one of the most underrated
supplements
there's fantastic human evidence that
creatine helps improve muscle
performance um in terms of training it
helps it may help improve brain function
um and also helps improve the exercise
recovery
and it's a safe molecule so
yeah i take creatine every day um yeah
we've already mentioned physician and
also take quercetin um again it's five
days in a row each month
um what else am i taking
omega-3 um
there is yeah i take omega-3 primarily
because of a um a mayo clinic trial that
what study that came out last year
and that meta-analysis it only included
trials where um omega-3 was compared to
placebo a few other meta-analyses that
said that there wasn't much of a benefit
of omega-3 it was including trials where
there was dietary advice as well so if
people are getting all of their omega-3
from you know lots of salmon for example
that you're probably not going to see
much benefit if you're taking a omega-3
supplement um whereas
yeah if you just take the trials that
look at um omega-3 compared to placebo
there does appear to be a benefit so i
take that and
yeah i also take vitamin d so that
that's
those are the main ones that i take i'm
curious so do you because last time we
chatted on when i had you on my channel
you weren't taking any supplements which
is something i i think is actually quite
a good idea
yeah so i mean i yeah i mean i've i
still trying to get my head around how
these seven things are working and i was
gonna mention one of the interesting
things that you did recently in your
channel was kind of break down your
recommendations for different age groups
and i think um our bodies obviously
change as we age um but also
what particular things would be
beneficial at different ages will also
uh vary so as we already mentioned with
protein and how you don't want to reduce
it too much when you're like over 65
roughly because that's when you're
starting to lose muscle and so
yeah i think that is really hard to do
to the limited data i don't want to do
anything whilst i'm young that might
have negative consequences especially
since there's no reason for me
necessarily to be doing anything at the
moment i mean in terms of
diet and exercise i do try to stay
healthy but i'm the same like i mean i
do prioritize my sleep probably too much
if i'm
for me video will sleep sleep comes fast
i'm a little bit bad about that but um
yeah so i think i try to just um
do what i feel comfortable with and just
go without um and make sure that i'm
happy and healthy um i like yeah so
going back to your point i um
i think it's interesting that
what we recommend should also be i don't
necessarily recommend anything but i
think it's important to understand what
these different molecules are doing and
to base your own opinions
on the data that we can present because
ultimately um
it's yeah everyone's got personal
differences and that's something as well
that's barely been looked at how genetic
differences environmental differences
might influence how these
um supplements work and i was going to
ask um with your trial like are you um
how like day first is the trial going to
be um is it based on new zealand only or
is it going to be international
yeah um i'll definitely answer that but
one of the points that i do want to
emphasize as well
when it comes to supplements so
yes there's a lot of noise around
different supplements and and how you
how you know different so-called
influences say that you should be taking
them i do want to emphasize that at best
right now it you we might be getting a
one percent gain what really matters is
diet exercise sleep meditation purpose
socializing those are the things that
that really matter for your health so i
just wanted to make that point um when
it comes to my initial trial so this
will just be new zealand patients
because it's a small trial of only
around 30 people for the much larger
superiority trial we'll need to do a
multi-center trial to do that because
trying to get 400 people to complete the
trial um
is going to be a significant challenge
so i'd hope to
yeah to have centers in new zealand
australia
possibly the us and possibly the uk if
if that's what we need to do
so it's yeah that the much larger
superiority trial is going to be
it's that's going to be a massive
undertaking and i think it would be um
yeah it would be pretty cool if we can
if we can complete that because again we
after that trial we will know
will rapamycin be useful
in
older people
because how like how how where does the
money mainly go does it mainly go to
coordinating the different assays that
need to be done or is it paying the
researchers who have to take the
measurements
yeah it's it's paying the researchers so
you know you've you've got to um you've
got to pay someone essentially to help
recruit the patients
you know run them through the the
questionnaires that this the safety of
it um
then you've got to um
yeah then you've got to pay someone to
follow the people up while they're doing
the trial to make sure that there's no
safety issues that they're actually
doing the exercises you've got to pay
someone to do the measurements of them
so you know we'll be doing the 30 second
chair stand test hand grip tests um the
six minute walking test you have to pay
someone to do that you have to pay for
the blood tests um you have to pay for
the ethics committee to have a look at
your trial um
yeah there's
there's a lot of stuff that that crops
up um so yeah it's expensive to do and
and then you to run a clinical trial as
well um
i didn't actually realize this but you
need an auditing you need a separate
auditing
uh company to make sure that you're
essentially not just making up
data
which is great but again that's all a
cost so it just keeps adding up
um so it'll be great it would be great
if we could
you know almost
you know just do this online like if you
could just do zoom consultations with
with people and get them to do the 30
second chair stand test
you know on on zoom but yeah it's
way more complicated than that
unfortunately yeah well i just knew from
like in the research lab there's so much
paperwork that goes into just doing a
mouse experiment so i'm like but when
it's humans there must be even more
paperwork right and it sounds like it
yeah no it's huge i've been so when i
started the write-up for this clinical
trial i thought oh yeah like get like a
four page thing together and
hunky dory but my gosh it just yeah you
you need to go through all of the the my
starter the existing human data that's
out there
you know really go into detail about
your hypothesis what your endpoints are
going to be
um
yeah it's significant so we have like a
team of people it's not just going to be
you right there'll be a team of people
helping you out
uh yeah so there's um there's a hospital
them that i'm working with um
so they'll be they'll be the ones
actually running the the clinical trial
so i'm i'm the so-called sponsor of the
trial and then um but
since i'm the sponsor i'm not allowed to
be the primary
um investigator
so
again have to pay someone to do that so
yeah it's
that's a lot but it's interesting like i
do think these types of trials will
move the field forward because it's
going to be robust it's going to be
bulletproof it's a functional outcome
people aren't you know in the medical
world they're not going to be able to
shoe this data away if if it proves you
know if we can do a randomized
placebo-controlled trial that shows that
yes there is a benefit to older people
and that's huge anyway like you know
having less people in rest homes and you
know more time out doing the things that
they want to do it's great for the
economy it's great for their you know
each person's life it's huge so yeah no
exactly yeah i agree i mean i mean i
guess it's somewhat reflected in trials
but also like just basic research
there's so many times when research is
published but it just wasn't controlled
correctly and it's like if you only did
this and it would have been fine and we
would have more data but yeah i know i
definitely think this will help um
contribute to the fields and i think
also be so one thing i was going to ask
you which i forgot to mention was how
would you like distinguish the benefit
if there's benefits right if it's the
exercise or the rapamycin like are you
gonna have a separate like exercise only
or rapamycin only but then the poles
study right that's just rapamycin so i
guess in theory you could
somewhat compare it with their results
so that the the trial will be
placebo-controlled okay so that so the
placebo group will be exercise we'll be
doing
some exercises yeah okay yeah so so that
yeah that's how we know will it so we
know that exercise improves muscle
performance in older people yeah so
yeah i don't
this is the thing that i don't really
understand about the pearl trial um
but i didn't see any imagination as well
right i feel like they were trying to
push that as one of their epigenetic age
as one of their main markers yeah they
are that's the secondary outcome um well
one of their secondary outcomes but yeah
i think i think we need to build upon
the work that's already been done and
that's why i want to combine the trial
with exercise we know that exercise
improves muscle performance so any
anything that we do needs to be combined
with exercise to see will it improve
uh sorry anything that we do to further
improve muscle performance needs to be
combined with exercise
we need to see if it's an added benefit
or not
yeah do you have any final advice for my
audience brad it's been great talking to
you today and hearing about this trial
um it sounds like you've got everything
kind of like
under control and planned um and so is
it just literally the fundraising left
to go before like you dive straight into
it
yeah so we've got the fundraising to go
um there's still a few things that we're
tidying up on the on the design itself
and then we'll be applying to the ethics
committee um but essentially we just
want to make sure that our write-up is
as clear as possible so i think right
now that the write-up's about 23 pages
long
and i think we've got a couple more
pages to to add so once once we have got
that all nicely signed off we'll send it
to the ethics committee and then
once that's approved we'll be
registering the trial um on the
different trial registries and again
that's important because if when you
register your trial on a on a clinical
trial registry you are saying this is
this will either make the trial a
success or a failure to do with the
primary outcome and and you're you're
you're laying your your neck on the line
if you'd like to say
yeah this will be a success or not um
and and that's important because then
there's no so-called p-value hacking
like we mentioned before
um
one of the things that i
i suppose i do want to touch on there's
um there's another youtuber
who i didn't actually realize that she
was a new zealander
and she um so she's a trained medical
doctor but she's not i don't actually
realize that she's not a practicing
doctor and because of the type of
content that she was creating she's now
being investigated by the new zealand
medical council and i just want to
highlight this because of the
i think it gives a good warning that yes
you might read
stuff online or listen to videos
online and this is including me as well
but
none of this should take away from the
um from the relationship that you've got
with your own medical doctor um and all
of this research that we presented it's
interesting but it's not um it is not
yet validated in in larger humans um and
larger human trials apart from things
like creatine so yeah i just want to
mention that to your audience as well as
don't necessarily believe everything
that you hear online which i'm sure they
don't anyway but yeah i think it's i
think it's an important point no
definitely and that was really well said
i can yeah i completely agree um yeah
don't
ignore everything i say
um but no you're right it's very
important that we make sure that message
is very clear um so yeah thank you for
coming on today i think we've kind of
jumped all over the place with different
topics but it's all been very exciting
and hopefully um our audience have taken
um away some musical insight from it so
if you haven't already go subscribe to
brad's channel um
he has awesome like digest of different
uh compounds different topics um and
even more frequent that person than i am
so definitely go check his channel out
um so yeah thank you for coming on uh
best of luck for the trial and i'm sure
as you progress we'll be catching up and
hearing how it's going so yeah that
sounds all very exciting
yeah thanks eleanor this has been a
blast so yeah we'll definitely keep you
updated and thanks for having me on no
problem thank you
so i hope you've learned something in
this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening
you